Serial killer Joe is back for the fourth
season of You, searching as ever for
redemption and now caught in the schemes
of a mysterious "eat the rich" murderer.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and
in this video I'm breaking down the big
twist in Part 1 of Season 4, clues you might
have missed, and predictions for Part 2.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Season 4 opens with Joe yet again thinking he
can put his murderous past behind him, this
time going by the alter ego Jonathan Moore,
an English literature professor in London.
Jonathan could be your chance to make
some different choices.
He then seemingly tries
to stay on the straight and narrow but
gets involved with a circle of wealthy
socialites and obnoxious British aristocrats,
and after a drunken night at an exclusive club,
he wakes up to find Malcolm dead in his flat.
Joe disposes of the body, and begins receiving
mysterious messages from the eat-the-rich
killer who next dispatches Simon and Gemma.
In the mid-season finale, things come to
a head when the loathsome aristo Roald
accuses Joe of being the killer and attempts to
execute him by hunting him through the woods.
Joe manages to stop Roald but then Rhys
turns up out of nowhere and knocks him out.
Joe wakes up and finds himself
chained in a dungeon with Roald,
and Rhys reveals he's behind the murders.
There were several clues to the close connection
between Rhys and Joe right from the first
episode where we can see how similar they are,
each having had difficult childhoods and
both being raised by a single mother.
Pleasure to meet you, brother in arms.
Rhys spent some time in prison when he was
younger and when he tells Joe that he relapsed
into alcoholism and fighting three times before
finally setting himself on a better path,
it's a nod to Joe's three attempts so
far to change his own life and escape his
murderous past in New York, first going to LA,
then on to Madre Linda, and now to London.
And it's no coincidence that Joe feels drawn
to someone who wrote a book titled
"A Good Man In A Cruel World".
So now I just try to do a bit of
good moving forward, just something.
As it reflects Joe's frequent misguided belief
that he's really just a good guy with noble
intentions who's messed up a few times, and
who's just trying to be better from now on.
Joe clearly admires Rhys and his tale of
how he went from a council estate to Oxford
University and is now trying to become
mayor of London, and so he asks him…
So you believe it's possible?
Redemption?
I think yes.
As long as they commit
to never run from themselves.
Face it all, no matter what.
Embrace everything, Jonathan.
Rhys is telling Joe he shouldn't
shy away from his darker side, and I think he
actually sounds a lot like Love Quinn here,
someone who also blindsided Joe when she
revealed she was a brutal killer just like him,
and who didn't really regret her actions, just
like Rhys doesn't in the midseason reveal.
By the way, we haven't seen Joe's infamous cage
that's appeared in every season of You so far,
but it's interesting how Rhys
still found a subterranean,
soundproof dungeon underneath Hampsbridge
House in which to lock up Joe and Roald.
There are a few details and clues
however, that hint at something
more going on beneath the surface.
First of all it seems strange that
Rhys is going on a murder spree of his wealthy
friends while simultaneously making his bid to
become mayor of London…
Call me crazy.
Feels like that will complicate
lurking anonymously to kill people.
Also having all of the murders apart from
one committed by someone other than Joe seems
like a bit too much of a repeat of what
happened in Season 3, as does having English
version of Joe after we've just had a female
version of Joe in the previous two seasons.
There's something odd about the way that Joe
always seems to be waking up just before he
discovers there's been a murder.
For example, he was blackout drunk
when Malcolm was killed;
he fell asleep outside
the gallery when Simon died;
and Gemma's murder appeared to
happen after he was knocked out after falling
through the window at Hampsbridge House.
There's also the first message he receives from
the killer "Hello, you" which has a real vibe of
Joe about it.
Hello…
You
And let's not forget
Nadia's first rule about murder mysteries:
Number one, there are no coincidences.
Someone who's also hiding some dark secrets
is Kate and her father who she described
to Joe as "the worst man alive".
Given what's been teased already,
I'm sure we're going to find out a lot
more about him and Kate's past in Part 2.
Kate told Joe that her family is even richer
than her old-money aristocratic friends, and her
father has been involved in all manner of dodgy
dealings from corporate cover-ups to falsifying
environmental reports, and I suspect there
may be some connection between him and Rhys.
Perhaps he's funding Rhys's election
campaign in return for dodgy favours?
Or, maybe more likely given Rhys's claims
that he's going to clean up the city,
perhaps Kate's dad wants to take Rhys down so he
can carry on his own dirty business more easily?
But despite Kate's protestations that she doesn't
want to be anything anything like her father,
could there be something she's not telling Joe?
There could be a little clue in the first Miss
Marple novel, "The Murder At
The Vicarage", that Joe picks
up when he decides to study the whodunnit genre.
In that story an extremely unlikable magistrate is
murdered by his wife together with her lover, and
they also plot to pin the blame on someone else.
In You, Rhys confesses that his original plan
was to frame Joe for the murder of Malcolm
– who like the magistrate in the Miss Marple
book was also hated by everyone around him.
Malcolm is trash.
And if we take the Agatha Christie
novel as a clue, it could suggest Malcolm's
girlfriend Kate was somehow also involved.
As well as having a similar look to Love Quinn,
Kate also gives off shades of Love from Season 2
who didn't care about Joe's history of murdering
Beck, and actually embraced his murderous past.
Your past doesn't scare me.
It can't be worse than mine.
She even sounds a bit like Joe's internal
monologue here in the opening episode
Good.
Perfect, you.
Like all three previous seasons of You
have managed so far, I'm expecting Part
2 to have some shocking twists.
At the time of writing this video,
I've only seen the first five episodes, but
I'll have a stab, pun intended, at some more
predictions for the Season 4 finale.
I've always thought that Joe's crimes
will eventually catch up with him, and he'll get
caught due to his sloppy execution at some point.
There is that jar of pee at
the Salinger house, after all.
If I get caught with this
blowhard, it'd be poetic justice.
Whether it's this season or a future final season,
I feel the time is nearing for some of Joe's
past to eventually come back to bite him.
Murder has a way of following you.
And you're not getting away with it.
Nadia will surely play some part in the
next instalment as she's been helping Joe
research whodunnits and always seems to be
popping up whenever he's up to something.
I thought you were breaking in.
Nope, sorry to disappoint.
And perhaps she'll end up with
her classroom rival, Edward.
These two are going to kill each other
or get married by the end of term.
Phoebe and Adam clearly have a lot of
issues to work through, to say the least,
and although she said she was going to leave
him, she seemed to get back together with
him at the end of the mid-season finale.
Also, I wonder if we'll ever find out the
apparently incredibly profound thing that Joe said
to Phoebe on that first night at Adam's club?
What you said to me the other night, I don't
know that I've ever been seen so completely.
A suspicious character I noticed a couple
of times who seems to be following the group
around is this photographer here who
was watching them at Simon's funeral.
Joe also ducked away from her when she
noticed him at Simon's art exhibition.
This is actress Alison Pargeter, one of
whose best-known roles was as a stalker
on the British soap EastEnders, and I expect
we'll find out what she's up to in Part 2.
Also I wonder whether we've
seen the last of Marienne?
Could she come back and try and reveal
Joe Goldberg is actually still alive?
And like I said in my original Season
4 theories video back in 2021, I'd love
to see Love Quinn somehow make a return,
perhaps as a hallucination to haunt Joe
from beyond the grave, like Beck has done before.
And there's a Part 2 preview which you might have
missed at the end of the credits for episode 5.
The teaser shows Love in what I think is the cage
and interestingly she's holding Rhys's
book "A Good Man In A Cruel World".
I think this is probably still just a dream
or the ghost of Love Quinn but either way I
can't wait to see her return.
And if you enjoyed this video,
do leave a thumbs up, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying You with me and hope you have
a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!